devant nos confrères le chef de l'état a
rappelé son intention de déjeuner une
fois par mois dans une famille française
la première fois à la fin de ce mois je
peux vous le dire dans la région
parisienne au cours de sa conversation à
bâton rompu hier
monsieur giscard d'estaing a confié que
son plat préféré était les oeufs
brouillés un plat simple mais at il dit
est difficile à réussir
alors puisque dans quelques semaines le
chef de l'état risque de frapper à votre
porte et que vous aurez peut-être envie
de lui faire plaisir et que vous ne
connaissez peut-être pas la recette des
oeufs brouillés et bien la voici savoir
faire des ouvriers au jambon voilà les
eaux du jambon blanc de paris celle
droit un petit peu de punch ever nous
connaissons pas pleurer une casserole en
cuivre et préférence là vous faire des
oeufs brouillés pour deux personnes il
est préférable de mettre quatre heures
par personne vrai jour
oui justement des oeufs brouillés pour
10 personnes est ce que c'est réalisable
vous pour 10 personnes pour une ménagère
je pense que ça va peut-être déjà assez
difficile en raison du récipient à
raison du récipient oui moi je devrais
avoir abandonné faire en plusieurs fois
quel est le con délicat dans la cuisson
le point délicat c'est de les faire
cuire doucement très doucement sur le
poids ni fourneaux on devrait même en
vas-y plfr au bain-marie ce qui pour moi
n'est pas très important voilà alors
l'ordre du mélange maintenant 10 ans est
revenu me la joue mais là je n'ai eu à
la spatule en bois tout à fait important
c'est maintenant un bon c'est uniquement
au moment où les oeufs sont choquants
mais la bonne phrase je mets un petit
peu de canpages
et voilà
il ya une quantité à respecter pour la
can ce prêche par rapport aux 2 par
rapport aux 13 ans qu'il faut aussi de
cuir a soufflé tout à mettre un petit
peu à la fin pour faire briller aux
oeuvres nous ne va maintenant pour
accompagner ceux ci je pense qu'il
faudrait boire avec des oeufs brouillés
bordeaux léger et avons déjà fait
justement est-ce que c'est léger
débrouiller
c'est assez léger un envoyé doit être
montrée voyez c'est là la réussite et
pour le foie pour le foie bien sûr je ne
pense pas que ça soit prêt en janvier
voilà vous savez tout il reste à espérer
qu'il y aura pas de pénurie 2 dans les
prochaines semaines en france